Michael Saylor the CEO of microstrategy
was on CNBC this morning and he was
dropping knowledge he explained exactly
why after buying billions and billions
of dollars of Bitcoin and now being down
on that trade he still thinks that
buying Bitcoin is a great idea in fact
he even says it's his best idea here's
what Michael said you'd love to just
start off on we just said I think it's
129 000 roughly a coin average price of
thirty thousand seven hundred spent
about 4 billion on it one would
anticipate if the uh if the price stays
where it is that's going to cause a
significant write down overall at least
your Auditors may ask for that you know
you've talked for years about the
financial flexibility owning all that
Bitcoin gives you I wonder if you
believe it also works in Reverse no I
think it's been a net positive we back
tested our strategy against every other
alternative and if you roll the clock
back to August 10th of 2020 when we
embarked on this journey Bitcoins
performed 10x better than anything else
Gold's down 10 NASDAQ is flat Bitcoin is
up 86 since that time over any time
frame two years four years eight years
bitcoin's the best performing asset I
can't come up with a better idea you you
can't come up with a better idea does
that mean that you would actually
consider buying more at these prices
yeah
um I think uh if you think about Bitcoin
if your time Horizon is one month it
looks like a volatile risk asset but if
your time Horizon is 10 years it looks
like a risk-off store of value Asset so
the crossover point is four years
nobody's ever lost money investing in
Bitcoin for four years and if you want a
surrogate for the book value of the
Bitcoin Network it would be the
four-year simple moving average the
simple moving average of Bitcoin over
four years is about 21
685 dollars uh Bitcoins only touched
that uh that point a couple of times in
its history it's been great buying
opportunities so is it a great buying
opportunity
absolutely
bitcoin's backed by the most powerful
secure computer network in the world if
I gave you a hundred billion dollars you
can't reproduce it and it's beyond the
nation-state attack or corporate attack
so once you understand that and the fact
that it's the singularity there's
nothing like it in the world then yeah
this is an ideal entry point to get into
this thing and part of this conversation
was all about the difference between
short-term speculators and long-term
investors as he said if you simply look
at Bitcoin over one month it looks like
a highly volatile asset but if you look
at it over 10 years it ends up actually
looking like a risk off store of value
and ultimately that is a key piece of
the Global Financial system and Not only
was Michael correct in mentioning that
four-year moving average but we also
could look at something like the RSI and
when we go and we take a look at that
chart it's literally at the lowest point
it's ever been before there's no one
single data point that actually points
to when you should buy or not buy but if
you continue to look at data point at
your data point after data point it's
becoming quite apparent that Bitcoin is
very cheap compared to its historical
positions central banks in their pursuit
to devalue currencies to continue to be
able to support the debt load that
countries have undertaken they have
gamified and turned financial markets
into casinos everyone is looking for a
new hit everyone is looking for
short-term profits how how can I find
something that doesn't go up 100 but
rather 10x or 20x that's not how
investing is supposed to work instead
having a long time Horizon and
understanding things that accrue value
over long periods of time that's really
where true fortunes are made Bitcoin is
the epitome of this no one who has
bought Bitcoin and held it for four
years has ended up losing money and now
as we
mature Bitcoin at twenty one thousand
dollars is obviously much cheaper than
it was at sixty nine thousand dollars
but all of the underlying fundamentals
from hash rate to lightning network
capacity are hitting all-time highs and
as we continue to watch this
decentralized digital open source
currency continue to gain Global
adoption many people are realizing you
have to lose the short term Speculator
mindset that is induced in the Legacy
Financial system and you have to become
a long-term thinker to become a true
Capital allocator what are you willing
to buy and hold forever that's usually
how Warren Buffett Charlie Munger and
some of the greatest investors of Our
Generation build their wealth and now an
entirely new generation is learning buy
great assets and hold them forever the
question is is Bitcoin that great asset
I tend to think so but you got to make
your own decisions